How did Egyptian hieroglyphs
give birth to the alphabet?
Even in these ancient times in monuments
have been sitting and weathering for
thousands of years on their
great murals and pillars.
You find rows of little
pictures, sorry, not pictures,
hieroglyphs sacred symbols,
but despite appearances,
this isn't some mysterious, very onic
picture writing. It's confidence.
One consonant signs, two consonant
signs, three consonant signs.
Oh, wall of consonants, plus a sprinkle
of logo grass for determinative.
It's not that Egyptian was a harsh
bowel list and desert of a tongue.
It's simply did not right at the bowels.
Imagine if you wrote this way,
would that work?
And then imagine if you could add in
logo graphs to make sure you really got
your point across.
Imagine you wrote like that and you're
thinking with hieroglyphs too difficult,
fine off to the caves with you where
you toil away with ancient miners on the
Sinai peninsula,
you and your fellow miners would find it
handy to leave messages for one another,
but there's no time for deep studies
of rows of fancy hieroglyphs in here.
You need to keep it simple.
If you want another major moments.
In the history of writing.
Your characters look like scratchy,
rushed version of those
glamorous Egyptian symbols,
but they're meeting
doesn't matter anymore.
Nothing but consonants and the same
symbol for the same continent every time.
Take this character in addiction.
It means health.
The Semitic miners are calling a house
a bet [inaudible] or top sounds suggest
that you can just take the first letter
of a word like the Egyptians had already
been doing with much of
their continent writing.
You end up with a letter for your sound.
Buh. Do the same thing with water,
which the Semitic speakers are calling
mem and you now have an mm sound with a
couple of dozen elegant simplifications.
You create a simple,
reliable list of consonants,
an alphabet,
and you've given generations of future
children the joys of reciting their abcs.
Actually at this point in history there
ab GDS sometimes called an object or ob
God because who needs that wishy washy.
See when you can just use an s or a
k after a long hard day of mining an
etching, you turn to find that someone's
been watching you this whole time.
She's a trader. A Phoenician merchant
who knows a good thing when she sees it.
She's already made major cash and the
paper business where they turned tufty
stocky, swampy Egyptian papyri this
into flat ink couple sheets of paper.
She rushes back home to
Phoenicia and smirks.
Think of the,
she has keeping track of whatever anyone
else tells her just by remembering
about as many characters as she has.
Fingers and toes.
All the kings can keep their up two's
hieroglyphs and their stone monuments.
The future of the Mediterranean will
belong to alphabets and paper writing is
going portable.
She uses this new found alphabetic
leverage to turn a huge profit across the
entire eastern Mediterranean,
leaving people inspired to adopt and
adopt her alphabet wherever she goes.
All this and she doesn't even write you
a thank you card. How hard could it be?
Writing is easier than ever.
It feels universal like writings
here to stay for everyone,
but there is a peculiar quirk
that's easier to spot. In hindsight,
you and your mind crew,
we're communicating in a Semitic
language Phoenicians a Semitic language.
All of these friendly shades of the
Phoenician alphabet were being used for
languages that sounded similar
and worked much the same way.
Even Egyptian though,
no Semitic language itself is at least
a distant relative of the Semitic
languages with a similar personality.
This continent,
alphabet is being tested in easy waters,
but history is shaking things up.
Who are merchant friend
comes back for your help.
She needs you to deliver your alphabet
to a very different people living along
her trade route.
Okay.
What will happen when the alphabet
gets leaked outside of the family?